- Un premier voyage au Canada
pour le secrétaire d'État
américain Antony Blinken.
ANTONY BLINKEN,
secrétaire d'État icicicain
- Je me réjouis aussi
surtout non seulement
de notre partenariat,
mais de notre amitié face
à ces défis et, comme disait
la ministre, au travail.
- Rencontre de membres
de la diaspora ukrainienne
dans un café...
(rires)
... séance de photos à la maison
d'accueil du gouvernement
canadien ont donné lieu
à des échanges amicaux.
Une discussion sur
la même longueur d'onde
avec Justin Trudeau, renforçant
l'idée que les relations entre
les États-Unis et le Canada
coulent de source.
- Our two countries
are the two most integrated
countries in the world.
- Et ce ne sont pas les dossiers
qui manquent sur la table de
travail : la guerre en Ukraine,
le droit des femmes en Iran,
la souveraineté de l'Arctique,
l'Entente sur les tiers
pays sûrs.
(tirs)
Puis, il y a la crise
sécuritaire et humanitaire en
Haïti. La manière d'intervenir
demeure une question délicate.
La ligne semble mince
entre une main tendue
et de l'ingérence.
"Nous avons tous les deux eu
des discussions avec différents
pays pour sonder leur intérêt
et leur volonté d'intervenir en
Haïti", indique Antony Blinken.
MÉLANIE JOLY,
ministre des Affaires étrangères
- Aucune décision qui va être
prise sans l'implication des
Haïtiens. J'ai toujours dit
que ce sera par et pour
les Haïtiens. Parce qu'au final,
c'est pour leur bien, parce que
présentement, c'est le peuple
qui souffre en Haïti.
Alors, notre objectif,
c'est de les aider, eux.
- L'ancien ambassadeur
du Canada en Haïti croit
que le gouvernement haïtien
doit d'abord se concentrer
sur la mise en place
d'un pouvoir légitime.
GILLES RIVARD, ancien
ambassadeur du Canada en Haïti
- S'il y avait une feuille de
route claire pour les élections,
je suis sûr que le Canada
s'engagerait à appuyer
un conseil électoral provisoire,
une mission de supervision
des Nations unies sur
le processus électoral,
en fait, le genre de choses
qu'on a faites depuis 20 ans,
mais ça prend ça.
- Ce sociologue croit que
le Canada doit intervenir,
mais avec prudence, pour éviter
de répéter les erreurs du passé.
FRÉDÉRIC BOISROND, sociologue
- Le gouvernement du Canada
qui prend le leadership de ça
doit trouver la voie de passage,
une voie de passage qui est
légale, une voie de passage
qui respecte la constitution
haïtienne, qui respecte
les règles internationales.
- Les voisins et alliés
s'entendent sur bien des points,
mais leurs visions des troubles
en Haïti divergent.
Pour les États-Unis,
c'est d'abord une question
de sécurité, alors que pour
le Canada, il s'agit plut
d'une crise humanitaire.
Ici Valérie-Micaela Bain,
Radio-Canada, Ottaw